[Music]
one issue that I think wants all of us
is enabling the disabled how can we make
it possible for people who have lost the
ability to use their limbs either by
amputation or by stroke how do we give
them a better life how do we make their
lives more enjoyable give them greater
mobility one of my colleagues going back
to my early days as a neuroscientist
John Donoghue has been fascinated in how
the part of our brain that controls
movements works it's called the motor
cortex part of the cerebral cortex it's
located just about here and we have
known freed many many many years that
signals from the nerve cells in that
part of the brain drive motions if I
want to reach out my arm to grab a glass
of water it signals from the motor
cortex that send their information down
the spinal cord in our back and then out
to the limbs if you've had a spinal cord
injury or a stroke those connections are
interrupted but John Donoghue understood
that just because the connections were
interrupted didn't mean that the motor
cortex wasn't working and he resolved to
figure out a way to pick up the signals
from the motor cortex and translate them
into either robotic arm or an
individual's own arm by connecting to
another set of electronics that could
drive the muscles in the arm of someone
who's paralyzed he and his colleagues
have invented in inter cortical brain
computer interface it's a very very
teeny set of electrodes it's about the
size of a baby astrum aspirin that has a
hundred very fine wires that can sit in
the motor cortex they pick up the
signals from the nerve cells in the
motor cortex and relay them to a
computer the computer then decodes the
signal and then can send that signal out
to a robotic arm or as I say through a
number of connections back to the
individual
zone armed and gives that individual the
ability for the first time since their
injury to feed themselves to grab a cup
of coffee and take a sip by themselves
so it gives them the kind of
independence they never had one of John
Donahue's colleagues dr. Leigh Hochberg
who's worked closely with him on these
experiments told me something really
quite extraordinary the whole world of
deep brain stimulation which is related
and it's a world that is related to
recording signals from the brain but
also driving brain activity by
stimulating electrodes in the brain and
this kind of deep brain stimulation has
proved effective for some kinds of
epilepsy it's proved remarkably
effective for some individuals with
Parkinson's has controlled their tremors
and there are a lot of possibilities the
problem with understanding the brain and
intervening is there are a billion nerve
cells in the brain and figuring out how
each one participates in an activity is
a daunting task to put it mildly but
what these experiments suggest is that
we may not need to do a cell by cell
analysis we may not need a cell by cell
understanding of the circuitry that
drives a particular activity an activity
we want or an activity we don't want we
may be able to operate at the level of
ensembles of neurons and this is what
happens when we use deep brain
stimulation to control epilepsy or
control Parkinson's what dr. Hochberg
told me about was his dream and it is
really a quite inspiring dream besides
epilepsy there are other diseases that
are intermittent and he suggests that
perhaps or something is complicated in
schizophrenia where some of the time an
individual who has schizophrenia will be
functioning absolutely normally and then
the brain departs from a normal function
into an aberrant
which is manifest in all of the signs
and signals of schizophrenia what he
suggests that we may some day and let's
hope the not so distant future to be
able to record from an individual's
brain and understand when the signals
begin to move into the schizophrenic
mode and perhaps be able to stimulate
the brain to correct that back to the
normal mode
[Music]